what is opportunity how do you have a
good opportunity versus bad opportunity
i see it as three variables so you have
the total number of potential units to
sell how many units of this widget could
i potentially sell number one number two
is what is the value to cost discrepancy
so how much profit can i potentially
make solving this particular problem and
then number three is what are the
competitive dynamics within that
marketplace so
uh an example that has two of the three
would be like what if i wanted to sell
cell phone service
lots of people need it
the how much it cost me to add an
additional customer is very very low so
very high gross margins but what are the
competitive dynamics well there's a lot
of really entrenched players it's very
hard to get into that right and so when
i'm looking at an opportunity i want to
see all three the difficulty with using
those three is that that equation can
evolve over time and so if you're
starting a business right now you might
not have you know sell something that
everyone in the world can buy but as you
get into business you learn more
and then you realize that you can expand
your market in one way or another